[Musique]
5h du mat j'ai des frissons je claque
des dents et je monte le son seul sur le
lit dans mes draps bleu froissés c'est
l'insomnie sommeil cassé je perds la
tête et mes cigarettes sont toutes
fumées dans le cendrier c'est plein de
clines avec cette bouteille vide je suis
tout seul tout seul tout seul pendant
que Boulogne se désespère quoi me
remplir un dernier verre en tombant sur
le lino je me coupe la main ramassant
les morceaux je stérilise des murs qui
dansent l'alcool ça grise et ça commence
[Musique]
sur les moutons sur le parquet
et à ce moment là qu'est-ce que vous
avez fait je crois que j'ai remis la
radio
[Musique]
les étoiles
6h du mat faut que je trouve à boire
nique cœur fort tout café noir je peux
l'info rouge police patrouille je serre
les fesses il y a rien qui passe 4 5
francs-maros crie le Petit Chose dans le
matin rouge car mon nom digne sous ce
contenu
barge pousse la porte et je viens
m'asseoir toi 4 petites le carton dans
les waters toutes sales au bar dans un
coin noir une blonde platine sur sa
fille elle dit champagne je la compagne
du 50 je dis ça me tend et vous êtes
rentré comment dans ma voiture ah il y
avait toujours ma mère à la radio
[Musique]
que de pression dans les bars
c'est magnifique
7h du matin l'hôtel je paie j'abrège je
fouille mes poches je sais c'est moche
son sourire rouge son corps qui bouge
elle fait glisser son cœur croisé sur ça
pour bronzer t'as les bas nylon qui
filent sur le tendon ces ongles
m'accrochent tu viens chérie le lit qui
craque et les volets éclatent seul dans
le lit dans ses draps froissés sur sa
police mes doigts de la CGL prend la
pose pense à autre chose ses yeux miroir
on voit mon regard des anges pressés
dans ce bloc assez il me dit c'est
l'heure tandis quelle heure
et vous vous souvenez vraiment par le ce
qui s'est passé non vraiment
[Musique]
mon Dieu je peux même pas jouer là
il faut dormir alors je me sens dans le
matin gris c'est pas un jour et pas taxi
mais chaque histoire
plus facile c'est insoumise
plein la tête mes cigarettes sont toutes
fumées dans le centre de l'espace qui
n'accepte je suis toute seule toute
seule toute seule
j'ai trop le remplir un dernier verre
claque fait le verre en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]